let's talk about the process by which
this vaccine medic can be implemented
right so ben shapiro tweeted there's no
force in this country that's going to be
able to implement biden's vaccine
mandate you know once your company is
100 people then you got to test weekly
there is are edges there is a force that
can do it for one yes if they do
bounties you know if they're like snitch
on your your company and we'll give you
a reward but it's very it's really
simple i mean it's the irs
it's
the irs simply says
every year when you fire paperwork for
each employee you have to include
their their proof of vaccination with
your tax return
and if they're not vaccinated your
weekly test of theirs which is 52 per
employee times a hundred which is just a
ridiculous cost at a baseline
and if you don't if you miss one or lose
one fourteen thousand dollar fine and
it's gonna be on you per incident that's
what i'm saying if you have 52 per
person
and you miss one
14 grand imagine you've got an envelope
full of the with all the papers for the
52 weeks of proof and then your dog eats
it well there's 52 times 14 000 they're
gonna tax you for your small business or
a large business
now here's the question
do you think
law enforcement will come out to serve
uh see property seizures and arrest
warrants for tax evasion when the ir
they don't have to they don't have to
you know what they can just lean your
account without doing it without even
police action they just
i i understand your finances but i'm
asking if tax evasion
is is you're criminally charged yeah
because what happens is
you you you get fined the irs fines you
uh you know 15 grand right 14 grand and
you don't pay it and they say you know
you're in debt and then you try to get
around it so then they put the pressure
on you
i'm not saying they would do this they
can enforce it this way but i'm just
saying
if a warrant was issued due to failure
to pay taxes or some some criminal
liability to find within the tax code do
you think that cop is going to be like
for the vaccine mandate that's wrong or
they're going to be like tax avoider of
course tax avoider yep yeah they just
get their marching orders and they go do
it and they probably won't even get an
order to be like this is for the max the
vaccine this is just a tax avoidance
they're going to say this is a business
who owes us 200 000 in taxes they've
been avoiding they've been given
multiple warnings we've seized their
assets but now they're trying to
obfuscate their debts
how about this what happens if a company
tries arguing that oh this is the proof
of vaccination and they say oh that's
fake right don't get me trouble so so uh
i i've been a bunch of points i remember
in the in the late 90s my first job was
working for a consulting company that
was still doing savings and loan bailout
work from the 80s so an entire industry
was built around what happened with the
savings loans in the 80s an entire
industry has just been born
just been birthed
around the vaccine mandate around around
vaccine compliance around vaccine audits
around uh testing audits and like all
the and negotiating and litigate like
that this is a massive industry that was
just created overnight and there's a
thousand million consultants out there
jumping at the bit to start their own
business about in this field but the
thing that troubles me the most about
this is that biden knows that he has no
legal constitutional standing to do what
he's doing and the way that you can tell
that is that each part of their plan
is like comes out of one weird obscure
angle one bit comes out of osha another
bit on the housing part comes out of the
cdc
it doesn't make any sense and all that
says is that they pre-textually need
want to accomplish something
and then they go about finding the way
to get that done rather than
using their constitutionally granted
powers to exert the things that they've
been elected to do the whole thing is a
freaking joke the whole thing is tyranny
we are not living in a republic you do
not have the choice your representatives
did not debate this there was no debate
on the floor there was no vote you did
not consent to this and now it is being
enforced upon you and it's not going to
be
by gun it's going to be by liens and
seizures right they're just going to
snatch your stuff you're going to have
your bank you're going to hire lawyers
and accountants to fight this back your
second amendment rights don't have
anything to do here you're not going to
be able to defend yourself with your
ar-15 against an oncoming onslaught of
police coming to get your stuff you're
gonna have to hire ar-15 worth of
lawyers and accountants to protect
yourself you can't defend your your bank
account with a gun right so i'm saying
you have to your second amendment here
is being able to hire lawyers
being able to hire accountants to defend
you from these liens and seizures that
are going to come 14 000
per incident and so what i believe would
end up happening is
take a look at the eviction moratorium
stuff it's going to be it's going to be
cops enforcing this
and they're going to say dude i don't
know what you're talking about this says
failure to appear this you know you you
at a summons this says tax evasion
you're a criminal i have a story just
like this i when i got doxed in 2018
i was in an ongoing online dispute with
my former employer and i tweeted out to
them i said you think i'm going to go
into the dark quietly i'm going to burn
this whole thing down figuratively of
course it was figuratively it was
singing the blues okay
what happens at 11 o'clock at night bang
bang bang bang bang on my door
i'm in bed my kids are in bed i go
downstairs freaking butt naked
and there are two detectives
with the with the badges hanging around
their neck and a bulletproof vest and
and the windbreakers on and they had
eight and a half by eleven printed out a
sheet that just said i'm going to burn
this whole thing down i was like what
are you here for what are you here for
the tweets dude we're here for the
tweets
we're here for the tweets they didn't
know why they got sent they didn't know
the context they didn't know that i was
an ongoing dispute they didn't know that
i was a writer they didn't know that i
was literary in my word usage they just
had a tweet and they don't care and an
eight and a half and eleven blow up of
my driver's license
and they were just like this is this you
yes did you say this yes step
outside that's what's going to happen a
million times over and over again
it's scary
yep so
they can't enforce it
and i think you know people shouldn't
get caught up in this one particular
thing either the eviction moratorium was
government theft of property
at at a national level government theft
of property and you end up with the
here's here's why i'll tell you this
there's there's a lot of hit pieces
that'll come out be like tim poole
claims to be center left and it's like
well yeah because i can literally talk
about my policy positions and what that
means for being left libertarian
but is hassan the sauna left libertarian
no he's in favor of the government
seizing your property
of the government the authority taking
property from the working class away
from them he's in favor of executive
decree mandating people be medicated
same thing is true for vosh they're not
libertarians they can you know respect
for washing coming on the show and
having these debates but he says he's a
libertarian socialist no he isn't he
celebrates the government mandating
forced medication on the people okay now
i get it first medication if it's a
legislative decision there's a
democratic process of liberty where it's
like we've come together to have a
discussion about what is right for the
community some people won't like it but
hey in a republic you don't always win
and that means some people will still
have to abide by an authority but not
authoritarianism which would mean
my view is oh vaccine mandates if
there's a long process if there's
long-term studies if it's been argued
out in in in the public and we're not in
a state of panic when we do it
authoritarian position is the executor
and sovereign shall decree the plebs do
as they're told man you keep using this
word sovereign the people are the
sovereign that's the point i know it
just when you say it you're triggering
you're triggering me each time because
the people are the sovereign now i
understand that in cases of emergency
the executive needs to act in a way that
um would solve time problems around the
legislature convening to debate and to
legislate right okay and that and that
concept is born of the fact that when
john adams had to go to the
constitutional convention or whatever he
had to ride a horse it took him you know
freaking four weeks to get there but
today yo
okay thomas massey will explain this
very well that the legislators could be
in dc in a matter of hours
it's been 18 months
or zoom
right there's been it's been 18 months
and they have not convened a session to
my knowledge
on the floor of congress to be like hey
all
what should we do about this corona
thing maybe they should what do you mean
maybe they should
just do it gd they should do it
gdp they should do it i'm sorry people
the absence of your legislature's
legislating and debating on these things
that impact your day-to-day life is a
sign you're living under a tyrannical
rule it's tyranny
they just voted newsmen
they love it bro they don't gotta admit
these people are sitting there with
their hands like this with a boot and
they're going
just licking it and then they're smiling
while they do it and they're like why
won't you lick it
you know what you want to know what it
is
you ever see this video where the guy's
in a mall or
he's in a supermarket
and he's got a mask and there's a woman
filming and he's stalking her around
yelling at her for not wearing a mask
and he goes is anybody else mad that we
have to wear masks and she doesn't
oh right let's get her and that explains
a lot of it yeah not all of it but a lot
of it there are people who are like
well if if i don't you know uh help the
the authoritarians then they'll come
after me so i have to do it then when
they get mad they have to do it and see
someone else who's not doing it they get
angry right they're like well i have to
do what you do too
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you